[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم حلقه جديده من
حلقات الاعلام الاسرائيلي وما يجري في
دوله الاحتلال وزميلنا الدكتور احمد فؤاد
انور مساء الخير معال الدكتور اهلا سيد
صديق العزيز الله يخليك ويحفظك كان عندنا
اسبوع حافل ولكن انا من بين الاخبار
الثيره التي تابعناها والتي ارسلتها ل
توقفت واستاذن نبدا بها وهو
مؤتمر اعاده الاستيطان في غزه او مؤتمر
غزه كما سموه مؤتمر عجيب غريب انه مسؤولين
اسرائيليين يقيموا هذا المؤتمر الذي يدعو
الى طرد الفلسطينيين والاستيطان في غزه في
ظل الغضب الدولي من هذه المخططات هل ممكن
تدينا فكره من الالف كده يعني بدايه ما
هذا المؤتمر من ايده ومن عارضه يعني بعدها
لحضراتكم المشاهدين طبعا في مجموعه من
المتطرفين في كل اماكن العالم المشكله ان
في وزراء ان الحكومه نفسها الاسرائيليه
فيها 11 وزير حضروا هذا المؤتمر الذي يدعو
الى اعاده استيطان قطاع غزه واتوا بخريطه
جاهزه هنا وهنا وهنا سنعيد بناء استيطان
غزه
من خلال خريطه جاهزه وان هذا هو الذي يوفر
الامن لاسرائيل هذا هذه ليست فقط وصيه
دينيه انما في قدر نفعي في الامر المشكله
الاخطر ان هم بقياده بنفير قالوا هتافات
تدعو للتهجير اللي هو وزير الامن الداخلي
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي بيقول تهجير
الناس ترد وراه ترانسفير اه ترانسفير فنوع
من الهوس اللي يعني طبعا المحكمه محكمه
العدل الدوليه
هتتلف فريق الدفاع القانوني الجنوب
افريقيا هيتل قفه يعني فده امر الامر
الثاني هذا يثبت انه
اسرائيل عقدت العزم على مساله تهجير سكان
غزه بالقوه ما يخالف القانون ويورث
اسرائيل امام محكمه العدل صحيح فهو كان في
هستيريا كان في حشد كبير كان في اعلام كان
في لافتات
وبيتصرف لافته كبيره برض تم تعليقها في
مفرق طرق مهم محوري بيقول الشعب يريد
الانتقام يعني بعد 120 يوم بعد حوالي
100000 قتيل شهيد ومصاب لسه يريدون
الانتقام ده انت بتربط بين ده وما بين
المؤتمر ولا دي حاجه مالهاش نفس الافكار
نفس المجموعه فطبعا ده حتى رفع شعار الشعب
يريد الانتقام اه الشعب يريد الانتقام فده
من
ضمن الهستيريا اللي بتسيطر على المجتمع
الاسرائيلي
فجم نتنياهو بنفسه قال لا احنا مش وش ذلك
وتصريحات احنا وش ذلك ده بعد الشعرات دي
ولا بعد مؤت المؤتمر بعد المؤتمر على طول
لا الشعرات دي شغاله على طول موت العرب
يعني لان كان في مره في فريق اسرائيلي
استعان باثنين من الشيشان اين لاعيب
الكوره مسلمين ولا يجوز والهتافات في مدرج
كده بيبقى مخصص للالتراس بتاع فريق بيتر
القدس ف الدنيا قامت ان ازاي يجيبوا
مسلمين يلعبوا في طبعا في دلوقتي من
فلسطين ال 48 بيلعبوا انما برضو بيبقى ف
اه تفات ضدهم كل فتره
والثابت سباب في الاسلام وفي العرب هو ده
الكوره اه ده جزء اساسي ف نتنياهو بيحاول
ينفي جانتس قال لا انتوا كده بتضر بال
احنا ضد الموضوع ده جانتس اللي هو وزير
الدفاع السابق وعضو مجلس الحرب الحالي
فكان في ردود افعال بتحاول تقليص خاصه
نتنياهو بعد حكم المحكمه امر الوزراء بعدم
التصريح تتكلموش كتير يعني بشان القرار
بتاع محكمه العدل الدوليه احنا لسه بندرسه
احنا بنحاول نفهم بنحاول نصيغ فما حدش
يتبرع وهو طبعا
بنفير على طول سبق وشتم في وجه سباب
وسخريه من المحكمه الع طب خلينا عشان يبقى
الكلام برده ايه يعني نبقى في نفس الموضوع
احنا عندنا مؤتمر غزه اللي عقد يوم 28
يناير الماضي اظن الحد اللي فات المؤتمر
ده في في في ظل هذه الهوجه ورغبه اسرائيل
انها تقنع المجتمع الدولي ان هي مش دوله
مارقه على القانون الدولي وتحاول ان هي
تسترضي وترسم صوره ايجابيه جاء هذا
المؤتمر ليثبت جانبا كبيرا مما قالته جنوب
افريقيا في دعواها صحيح هذا ما حدث وانت
بتقول اللي قاد هذا المؤتمر هما نفس
الوجوه المتطرفه اللي بتقو تقريبا المؤسسه
الحاكمه في اسرائيل بن غفير وس مترش وزير
الماليه الى
اخره بعد المؤتمر نتنياهو تبرا من من
مخرجاته رغم ان في 11 وزير في حكومه
وشاركو بالضبط طيب اشهر ردود الفعل
الرافده خلاف نتنياهو مين طبعا يعني ياير
لبيد يعني زعيم المعارض طبعا تلقى في
الموضوع دوت وهاجم بشده قال ان ده بيسيق
لصوره اسرائيل اللي هي متدهوره بشكل عام
في الفتره الحاليه فهو بيعترض على المؤتمر
وعلى السماح ليه ودع لصحب الثقه يعني في
حزب العملته اه ص حزب العمل هو كان بيدعو
في الشارع حزب العمل دعى في الكنيست سموه
اي امون يعني سحب
ثقه دلوقتي في من يش عتيد اللي هو حزب
يائير لابيد اللي هو زعيم المعارضه بيقود
عرض تاني بسحب الثقه او مقترح تاني بسحب
الثقه فهو
طبعا المجموعه
المتشدده بتقول لا هو ده الطريق واحنا
المفروض نكثف من الموضوع ده كمان في الضفه
احنا حوالي 15 كيلو بس من ساحل البحر
الابيض المتوسط تله ابيب والساحل بعمق 15
كيلو انما احنا عايزين نخش للضفه نامن
انتشارنا فيها والاستيطان يبقى اكبر عظيم
جدا طيب بما ان احنا اتكلمنا على المؤتمر
ا مؤتمر غزه ايوه اللي هو المفروض انه
وفقا لفعالياته ومقرراته يورد اسرائيل
بشكل ما امام محكمه العدل الدوليه نسال هو
اسرائيل يعني كان رد فعلها ايه على قرار
محكمه العدل الدوليه يعني معسكرين انقسم
الراي العام في اسرائيل ل معسكرين معسكر
طبعا بيقول الحمد لله يعني كده احنا عدينا
نفدنا من وقف اطلاق النار الفوري ما قالش
وقف اطلاق الفوري فده كده حاجه ممتازه
الحاجه الثانيه ان ادانا شهر ان محكمه
العدل اجتمعت وتبنت ست قرارات ست تدابير
عاجله من تسعه مطالب قدمها فريق قانوني
جنوب افريقيا
ف اسرائيل قالت احنا تمام ما فيش وقف
اطلاق نرض حاجه جيده جدا الحاجه الثانيه
ان بدل الاسبوع اللي كان جنوب افريقيا
بتطلب تنفيذ في التدابير دي وتقدم للمحكمه
ما يفيد بان انا اتخذت اجراءات لتنفيذ
التدابير قالوا شهر فده فسحه من الوقت ان
انا انجز بعض ما اريده في قطع غزه انما في
المقابل قالوا لا احنا الابعاد معسكر تاني
بقى بيقول في المقابل الذين يون انها
لاطمه كبرى لاسرائيل بيقولوا لا احنا
ابعاد الصوره بتاعتنا اللي
اتشوهت لا يمكن توقعها لسنوات قادمه فده
الضرر الاكبر حتى اكبر من القضات نفسها
اللي طلعش طبعا اذكر يعني الاصدقاء انه
طبعا في عندنا حلقه كامله بتشرح كل ما
يتعلق
بلجوء جنوب افريقيا لمحكمه العدل الدوليه
استاذنكم ان تعودوا اليه لكن بايجاز شديد
جنوب افريقيا تقدمت بطلبين طلب عاجل الشق
المستعجل وهو باختصار ايقاف الحرب
والعدوان على الشعب الفلسطيني في غزه من
خلال تسع اجراءات والشق الاساسي بقى طبعا
وهو ادانه اسرائيل بتهمه الاباده الجماعيه
تهمه الاباده الجماعيه كان اهم انجاز فيها
ان المحكمه قبلت النظر في القضيه اصلا مش
كده برض يا مع دكتور يعني كان ممكن
المحكمه تقول بدايه هذه القضيه برمتها ليس
من صلاحياتي فمجرد قبول المحكمه النظر في
القضيه انجاز كبير طيب في الشق المستعجل
بقى كان في تسع اجراءات كلهم هدفهم اللي
هو تخفيف العدوان على الفلسطينيين واهم
هذه المطالب هو وقف اطلاق النار فورا
فالمحكمة هي لم توافق على الوقف الفوري
لاطلاق النار
واهلت اسرائيل شهرا للابلاغ بان التدابير
يتم تنفيذها ايوه تمام من خلال تقرير خلال
شهر يتم صياغته المفارقه طبعا ان القاضي
الاسرائيلي تضامن ووافق على بندين من ال
اه اللي هو بخصوص التصريحات منع التصريحات
الداعيه للاباده اه وادخال مساعداه طبعا
ماوش م ن الاوغنديه هي اعترضت على كل
القاضيه الاوغنديه دي فطبعا الراي العام
الاسرائيلي هي عملت ايه الاول هو تحفظت
ورفضت ان المحكمه ليها صلاحيه وكل البنود
رفضت رفضت كانت برض لافته الراي العام
الاوغندي والرسمي قالوا احنا نتبرا منها
ده متحدث رسمي قال احنا مالناش علاقه
موقفنا في التصويت ثابته مع القضيه
الفلسطينيه الحاجه الانيه انه بتوع التيك
توك اللي هما قالوا لها ايه اللي ماسكاه
عليك الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه تخليكي
تتخذي مثل هذا القرار وهذا التصوير طبعا
للتذكير مره اخرى اعضاء محكمه العدل
الدوليه هم 15 اساسيين ثم بيضاف اليهم
اثنين من اصحاب طرفي النزاع فاضيف اليهم
قاضي اسرائيلي وقاضي من جنوب افريقيا من
بين القضاه ال 17 بقى قاضيه اوغنديه ف
الملفت للنظر انه المحكمه لما
قبلت الطلب جنوب افريقيا ووافقت على معظم
طلباتها انه القاضي الاسرائيلي وافق على
اثنين من طلبات جنوب افريقيا العاجله
التسعه زي مثلا وقف الخطاب التحريض ضروره
ادخال مساعدات الى غزه الملفت للنظر ان
القاضيه الاوغنديه رفضت كل مطالب جنوب
افريقيا كانت يعني اسرائيليه اكثر من
الاسرائيل ايوه بالضبط كده فكانت ا يعني
امر مثير
للغيبه ولفت الانتباه يعني انا سامع ان في
حمله كراهيه ضد جنوب افريقيا داخل اسرائيل
ايوه طلعوا لهم في علم جنوب افريقيا فرئيس
بلديه من بلديات الاسرائيليه لاحظ ان
الشارع في اعلام لدول منها جنوب افريقيا
فجاب الاعلام وهو بيعمل الانجاز الرهيب ان
هو بيسقط علم
جلو طيب معالي الدكتور احنا عندنا في حدث
في حمله ثانيه ضد الاونور والله اه ايه
صحيح كنت لسه اسالك عليها يا صحيح ايوه
طبعا ادينا فكره الاول كده لم لا يعلم ايه
هي يعني وكاله الاونروا بتعمل ايه وايه
المشكله الاخيره هو في قرارات من الامم
المتحده من بدايه من سنه 48 ومتكرره باغا
سه اللاجئين توظيف اللاجئين حق العوده
للاجئين بالنسبه للاجئين الفلسطينين
فلسطينيين طبعا 48 فمن ساعتها ف ايه اللي
بيترجم ده ايه اللي الاليه ايه هو الزراع
اللي ممكن ننفذ بيه ده هي الاونور وكاله
غس وتشغيل اللاجئين هم حوده تبيعه للامم
المتحده ففي 300 35000 في الشرق الاوسط
مالناش دعوه بيهم في غزه بس 13000 موظف
تابعين للون اخصائي اجتماعي
مدرس
وهكذا ف 13000 دول اونور نفسها الامم
المتحده نفسها قالت ان في تسعه منهم خلفوا
التعاقد التعاقد ان انت ما بكش انتماء
سياسي لا مع حماس ولا الجهاد ولا فتح ولا
اسرائيل ولا غيره الاداره ولا غير الاداره
ففي واحد عمل لايك على بوست في واحد شارك
يوم سبعه لايك على بوست ضد اسرائيل اكيد
مثلا اه ففي تسعه قالوا والله احنا بنقول
ان الجماعه دول يقاله من في تسعه بيقولوا
ايه التحقيق اصفر على ان في تسعه
من الموظفين يتم اقالتهم لمخالفتهم
التعاقد اه التحقيق ده بدا امتى مثلا يعني
الاون هي اللي كشفت الموضوع من حوالي شهر
وهي اللي اعلنت النتائج من ايام فاسرائيل
عشان تشوش على محكمه العدل الدوليه وهي
عملت كذا محاوله للتشويش منها انها بعتت
وفد من خلال شركه علاقات عامه ل للتشويش
على قرار المحكمه وعلى الراي العام في
لاهاي فبعتت الاسرى عائلات الاسرى
والمحتجزين وبعتت خمسه من الجنود والضباط
الذين شاركوا في قطاع غزه في العمليات على
اساس ان هم هيروق لان اسرائيل مش من
اخلاقها ابدا انها تقتل الناس واحنا كنا
بنوزع لبن عليهم وشوفان
وشوفان فالمهم ان هم من ضم فشلوا في
المهمه دي فشلوا في المهمه والفلسطينيين
لحقوهم يعني رفعوا شكوه
ضدهم من ضمن التشويش الاونور يا جماعه
الاون طلع فيها تسعه موظفين مع حماس اه بس
النقطه هنا الاساسيه انه انه وكاله
الغوث للاجئين او الاونروا هي من اجرت
تحقيقا في اداء فتحت موظفيها في قطاع غزه
واكتشفت ان هناك تسع موظفين خالفوا قواعد
التعاقد الا تكون جزءا من اي تنظيم صح
المخالفه دي تبدا من ان انا اعمل لايك
لبوست
او حاجه مكتوبه على السوشيال ميديا مؤيده
للفلسطينيين وضد الاسرائيليين وتصل الى
ايه المخالفات
التانيه المخالفات بقى ان اسرائيل بقى
اللي بتزعم ان في لا انا بتكلم على
الاونور الاول هل الاونور قالت ايه هي نوع
المخالفات دول مقالين لمخالفتهم التعاقد
ما قالتش تفاصيل اه بس واضح ان هو احيله
بسبب الاتهام الانتماء لتيار سياسي هو
فلسطيني اكيد اه اللي هو الاداره للقطاع
او واحد مواقفه كده فهو الفكره بس ان الت
دول اسرائيل طلعت بعد كده قالوا لا دول 12
اه مش 9 اه بعد كده قالوا لا دول 140 انا
عارفاهم كويس بدون
13000 فهو طبعا عارف حضرتك انت يقول لك
ايه شخص مشبوه نظم مؤتمرا مشبوها حضره
جمهور من
المشبوهين فيش حد بيتكلم كده انت في حد
محدد تعرفه عمل كذا وحققت في الموضوع
وتبين كذا ثاني حاجه انت لما في في
الجامعات الامريكيه اللي اتهم رؤساء
الجامعات بانهم غضوا الطرف او لم يصدوا
الهجمات المعاديه للساميه النبره ضد
اسرائيل داخل جماعتهم تم محاكمتهم بشراسه
وبشكل يعني برده فيه وقاحه بس في النهايه
انت ما عقبت الجامعه انت قلت رئيس الجامعه
ده غلط يمشي ما قفلتش الجامعه وقلت والله
دي فيها معادله دي نقطه مهمه جدا يا دكور
يعني الكلب مكين ده بقى فج وحتى في
استغفال في كروته انا عايز اظبط حاجه
معينه كتبه معينه لازم ابذل المجود شويه
بس معنى كلامك ان هم بيطالبوا
الان باغلاق الاونر و يعني الاسرائيليين
هو بيجفف المنابع زي ما عملوا مع الجامعات
ايه اللي خلى رئيسه الجامعه تستقيل في
هارفرد ان الممول المتبرع قال مش هتبرع اه
ما فيش انفاق ف بالتالي تم قبول استقالتها
او تقدمت باستقالتها فنفس الحكايه في
امبارح 13 النهارده بقى 14 دوله مانحه
للرا اولها الولايات المتحده بعديها
المانيا الاثنين دول لوحدهم نص مليار
دولار السيد طارو هم دول اكبر ممولين
ووراهم بقوا من ال 13 النهارده بقوا 14
اللي بالمجموع الباقيين دول ممكن يتجمع 50
مليون 60 مليون مش غ رقم بس موقف سياسي اه
انا دلوقتي بعاقب الناس اللي مستنيه
ت خيمه بلاستيك هو كلام الدكتور احمد برض
قال حاجه مهمه انه اذا كان في مجموعه
موظفين اه الموظفين دول اخطاوا بان هم
عبروا عن ميولهم السياسيه بتخ حكوا بشكله
او باخذ يوم س ايا كانت الجريمه اللي
ارتكبوها
ا و بانحيازه للجانب الفلسطيني خلاص ممكن
التحقيقات اثبتت ذلك يتم اقالتهم
واستبعادهم عند هذا يجب ان تتوقف المساله
لا يجب لا يجب ان تسلم الدول الاخرى
بالادعاءات الاسرائيليه ان هذا لم يكن
قصرا على تسع موظفين او 10 موظفين ولكن ده
غالبيه الاونروا ولا يجب معاقبه الاونروا
اللي هيكون عقابا للشعب الفلسطيني وكله
باعتبارهم ان هم المصدر الاساسي لمساعده
الشعب الفطين الحيا اه الوحيد وبيدي مثال
لما بعض الجامعات الامريكيه اتهم رؤساؤها
واتهمهم محل ديبيت يعني محل جدال لكن
نفترض يعني حتى وفقا للروايه الامريكيه
لما ثبت ان رئيس الجامعه ديت تهاونه في
ادانه
مظاهرات معاديه لاسرائيل خلاص يعني اقيل
رئيس الجامعه وظلت المؤسسه تعمل وانتهينا
يعني فهذا ما يجب ان يحدث لي الاونر مضبوط
يا مع دكور صحيح ففي من ضمن الحمله ديت
رسوم كاريكاتيريه ان في مكتب توظيف
الاونروا اللي واقفين كلهم ا من عناصر
المقاومه اللي جايب الار بي جي واللي جايب
العصابه بتاعته على راسه والزي الرسمي وفي
واحد في النص بنظاره زي حضرتك كده و
وجاكيت لطيف وبنطلون عادي فالعناصر
المقاومه بتقوله الله انت ايه اللي جايبك
هنا يعني دي الاونور انت جاي تبقى تشتغل
موظف في الاونور تبقى زينا فطبعا هو ده سم
في العسل يعني ان دول كلهم مسلحين وطبعا
ده غير صحيح يعني انا في حاجه المفروض ان
هي يعني يعني تبقى يعني طبعا ابتدينا
نحسها بس محتاجه تركيز شويه اسرائيل بقت
تقول كلام يعني يدعو للسخريه يعني دلوقتي
بقى يعني مثلا السكرتير العام للامم
المتحده هذا محامي حماس انت قلت نازي كمان
ده كلمه قاسيه جدا ان ده محامي حماس وان
جنوب افريقيا هي الذراع القانوني ل تركيا
ومصر وكل حاجه وتركيا ومصر وحتى قطر دول
اعوان حماس نفتح الحقيبه السوداء بتاعه
قطر يهددوا تز هنفتح الحقيبه السوداء لقطر
وغير قطر ثم يذهبوا الى ابعد من ذلك ان كل
مؤسسه وكل تقريبا العالم كله ضد باستثناء
الولايات المتحده وطبعا الجامعات اتهمت
بذلك الجامعات الامريكيه فاذا كان كل دول
ضد اسرائيل فالقصه يعني هم شايفين ان
العالم كله على فكره في حد انا مش قادر
افتكر اسمه كاتب كاتب مقاله جيده يعني
ممكن نبقى نشير اليها في حلقه ثانيه ان
اسرائيل تعتقد ان العالم كله ضدها اه لا
هي من الاول كده من ايام بنجور ان هو يقول
الامم المنتحله المنتحله المنتحله من
الوحل اه المتح اه طب ما الامم المتحده ده
اغلبيه اولا قرار طالعين بقرار منها ثاني
حاجه الديمقراطيه فين انتوا مش واحده
الديمقراطيه في المنطقه الجمعيه العامه
بالاغلبيه بتقول دول موصوم بكذا او ان هم
دول مره في الحس وما يطلعش منهم العيب طب
بمناسبه بقى ان احنا بنتكلم ان العالم كله
ضد اسرائيل جاه هم طبعا بيقولوا المناهج
المدارس بتاعه الاونه بتعلم قصايد منها
الاجانب والاغراب وبيطلعوا بقى اي حاجه في
المناهج اللي فيها مدارس الاونروا وان بقى
لهم سنين بيطلعوا يعني العيب مش في
الاحتلال اللي بيقتل الخدج انما المناهج
هي اللي فيها مشكله والمناهج دي بتدرس في
مدارس الاونر بمناسبه مدام انت مصر تعدنا
الى الاونر يعني ودي حاجه مهمه يعني بس
علشان انا كنت بفكر في حاجه ثانيه انما في
معهد اسمه جيت ستون على ما اذكر يعني جيت
ستون المعهد ده انا ابتديت اتابعه لما كان
جون بولتن اللي هو مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي
تراصوا وهو معهد شديد التعصب لاسرائيل
ومعادي لكل ما هو عربي واسلامي ولو كان في
وقت كنت اديتك امثله ام يعني بيذهب بعيدا
جدا مثلا مثلا يقولوا انا رايي ان العرب
دول بيحبوا الحرب ولكن لا يحسنو عاوز يدلل
على ان العرب العرب والمسلمين بيحبوا
الحرب يقول لك ايه شوف اسمائهم سيف حسام
ا حاجات كده يعني ايوه هيطلع اه انما هو
نفس المعهد ده كان مطلع مقاله يقول لك
محكمه الظلم الدوليه على محكمه العدل
الدوليه كان مطلع مقاله من كام سنه يقول
ققول لك ليه م انا عا ده هو بيقولوا كده
يعني اللاجئين تعالوا شوفوا اللاجئين كم
مليوم من كم دوله في لاجئين من سوريا
ولاجئين من اليمن ولاجئين من السودان
ولاجئين من اوكرانيا ليه بقى اونور ليه
الفلسطينيين لوحدهم يحظوا بكل هذا الدعم
هو الكود الهواء اه ليكود الهواء طب معالي
الدكتور كان في مؤتمر ميونخ للامن وده
مؤتمر دولي رفيع بيناقش قضايا الامن صح
وطبعا هو مؤتمر بيسيطر عليه طبعا الكتله
الغربيه بامتياز وان كان الجميع بيشارك
فيه كانت اسرائيل من الدول اللي بتشارك
زيها زي اي دوله في هذا المؤتمر بشكل سنوي
سليم لكن المؤتمر الذي سوف يعقد بعد حوالي
اسبوعين يعني في منتصف تقريبا فبراير
اسرائيل فوجئ بان في تطور لم يسعدها ما هو
هذا التطور ولماذا لو كان معتاد ان يجي
رئيس الوزراء يحضر مؤتمر ميونخ رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي وخصص لهما يعني قاعات كبرى
وحشد
وحديث منفرد فالمره دي ماسكين بيبتدوا
كريستوف اللي هو مدير المؤتمر كريستوف
هيوسون اللي هو الدبلوماسي الالماني اللي
بيشغل دلوقتي رئيس المؤتمر مؤتمر ميونخ
الام كان مستشار للمستشاره ميركل قبل كده
ف ابتدوا يطلعوا له بقى تصريحات انت ليه
اولا الخناقه على ايه لا وزير الدفاع يجي
من بين متحدثين مش بقاش متحد قولنا القصه
الاول قبل اشتباك مع كريستوفر هو مشكله
اسرائيل ايه في المؤتمر ده هي المفروض
هتحضر عادي هتحضر عادي وتصير ان يبقى في
متحدث وحيد ممثل ليها اللي هو رئيس
الوزراء متحدث وحيد ممثل ليها هو وزير
الدفاع في قاعه كبرى هم الجانب الالماني
بيقولوا له والله ما فيش امكانيه السنه دي
لان الاقاع والجدول وهكذا فال المتاح لو
عاوزين هم مش عايزينهم يجوا اه الالمان
يقول لهم لو عايزين في قاعه جانبيه وهيكون
فيها كذا متحدث يجي وزير الدفاع ويبقى من
ضمن المتحدثين ففي ابتزاز اسرائيلي ل
كريستوف اللي هو الاخ يوس نعم اه وبيقولوا
له انت كنت قلت بعد 7 اكتوبر ان في عقود
من الاحتلال هي اللي قادرت فبيطلع له اي
تصريح قبل كده ان هو ممكن يكون محايد ممكن
يكون منحاز للجانب الفلسطيني وده ما يصحش
اه فده الجزء اللي قبل كده في المؤتمر
اللي قبليه طلع نتنياهو بطياره مسيره
ايرانيه جزء منها وقال في خطر ايراني
ولازم كلنا ا كان بيعمل شو زي ما في الامم
المتحده كان يطلع يعمل قنبله نوويه ايران
قربت فضر لها كم يوم يمكن كذا فده كان
بيستغل كمنص للترويج للافكار الاسرائيليه
وفي ابتزاز حاليا لكي يكون بنفس ال قوه
كما كان في العام السابق يعني اذا اذنت لي
الخص القصه بانه اسرائيل ارادت ان تستغل
مؤتمر ميونخ للامن وهو مؤتمر رفيع دولي صح
ارادت ان تستغله كمنص للتعبير عن وجهه
نظرها وقد ايه هي متعرضه للظلم فيما يتعلق
بالحرب القائمه في غزه وانها الطرف الضحيه
لكن وعاوزه تعبر عن ده من خلال ان يفرد
للمتحدث من يمثله اذا كان رئيس الوزراء او
وزير الدفاع او الاثنين انه ياتوا يكونوا
متحدثين منفردين في قاعه كبيره حتى يكون
عدد الحضور كبير لكن اداره المؤتمر رفضت
وقالت ممكن تيجوا ولكن هتكونوا من بين
المتحدثين جدول المؤتمر لا يسمح بان
تكونوا منفردين وطبعا ارجو ان تصححي اذا
كنت اذكر يعني ان كريستوفر هيوسون ده اللي
هو الدبلوماسي الالماني هو فعلا كان ليه
مواقف تعتبر شويه مخضبه لاسرائيل لانه في
2000 و3 2004 كان بيضغط على اظهار احترام
وتفعيل اكبر لتقرير جولد ستون صح مش كده
برض اللي هو كان وثق جرائم اسرائيليه ضد
الفلسطينيين مضبوط صحي ايوه ده اعتداء على
غزه تم توثيقه فبالتالي هو منصف الى حد ما
بنسميه العدل المنقوص بس ده لا يرض الجانب
الاسرائيلي هو كان بيقول ببساطه تصريحاته
اللي اسرائيل بتشير اليها واعتقد ان هم
يعني مش محقين يعني هو فعلا قال كده قال
قال انه التاريخ لا يبدا من 7 اكتوبر وان
ما حدث من 7 اكتوبر وهو بيدينه بالمناسبه
لكنه هو نتيجه يعني اكتر من 50 سنه من من
الظلم والاعتداء
والاعتداء انت كنت في موضوع مهم قلت لنا
عليه وبعدين ربنا نصفك يا دكتور
يعني حكايه انه انت كنت مره قلت اكتر من
مره قلت انه مصادر تسليح المقاومه واحد
اين لاه في حلقه سوف اضع لكم رابطها لكن
قلت من مصادر التسليح ان المقاومه تحصل
على سلاح من داخل الجيش الاسرائيلي وان من
ياتي بهذا السلاح هم تجار سلاح او ضباط
هدفهم
الاساسي الربح فبيبقى لمن يشتري اللي
هيشتري مين في طرفين الجريمه المنظمه ودول
عاوزين اسلحه خفيفه في كل الاحوال اما
الاسلحه الثقيله فاكيد اللي هيحصل عليها
هتكون جماعات المقاومه مش ده اللي انت
قلته قبل كده كلامك ولا مش كلام انا انا
طيب انا لقينا بقى ايه العم سام بياكد
المعلومه لقينا اسرائيل طبعا العم سام حدش
يزايد عليه راجل بيفهم قال ايه الصحافه
الاسرائيليه العم سام طبعا الصحافه
الاجنبيه النيويورك تايمز قالت ان الجيش
زي تقريبا اللي انا قلته ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي هو المصدر الاساسي لل سلاح
المقاومه ف انا بشرح ثاني ببساطه وباختصار
السلاح المقاومه بياتي من مصادر ثنويه
منها التصنيع المحلي منها انا ما قلتش
الكلمه ده الكلمه دي او مره هقولها 50
مدرعه هديه من روسيا للسلطه الفلسطينيه ده
ايام عرفات ده بعد اسل يعني بعد العو بعد
94 في اسلحه رسمي دخلت عشان الشرطه
الفلسطينيه الامن الوقائي منها 50 مدرعه
هديه من روسيا دخلت من الاردن من ضفه جزء
منها كبير راح للقوه 17 وجزء صغير راح
للامن الوقائي الفلسطيني طيب في ايه تاني
في عرفات كان كل مره يطلع بالطياره يرجع
باسلحه هو كان
بيستعد لمعركه ولمواجهه وكان منها اسلحه
ايرانيه سقطت في يد الجيش العراقي توجه
توجه بها صدام حسين لليمن لتنقل الى
الاراضي الفلسطينيه عبر البحر اه فدي بكل
دي مصادر سنويه انما المصادر الرئيسيه هي
بيع جيش الاحتلال اسلحته للمقاومه من خلال
الوسطاء فاثناء الحرب حتى اثناء الحرب في
ثلاث وقائع موثقه لسرقه الاسلحه من جيش
الاحتلال وبيعها منها
ثلاثه خلال الايام الماضيه تم الاعلان
عنهم ان هم متورطين من جنود الاحتياط في
بيع الاسلحه الاسلحه دي عباره عن صواريخ
يعني ما ينفعش للجناين ابدا يعني ماينفعش
للجيبه المنظمه العاديه اه وال الحاجه
الثانيه ان القواعد نفسها اللي بيتم
دخولها يوم 7 اكتوبر غلاف غزه كان في
قواعد عسكريه تم اخذ الاسلحه طبعا منها
برض في اليوم ده بشكل او باخر يعني في
حاجات بغض البصر وفي حاجات بالقوه يعني
فده المصدر اللي بتكلم عليه ان هو مصدر
رئيسي للتسليح المقاومه ياتي من جيش الا
للال عبر وسطاء يتم بيع الاسلحه
الاسرائيليه تحت دعوه انها مسروقه انما هو
بيقول فقدت سرقت انما هو في
النهايه المعدل كبير جدا فبالتالي يؤشر
الى ان الاسلحه اللي دخلت زي ام 16 كذا
امريكي اسلحه امريكيه اتت فهو القطاع لا
ينقصوا سلاحا يعني بيقول لك محور
فيلادلفيا وبيخش من تحت الانف الانفاق
اسلحه قطاع غزه لا ينفقه لا ينقصه ينقصه
اغاثه ينقصه عداله ينقصه انصاف انما اللي
شغل نفسه اسلحه ومحور فيلادلفيا ما يفكرش
الاتجاه ده والله ده كلام مهم وهنضرب نعود
له مره اخرى انا بس لانه اول مره ذكرته
لقيت بعض التعليقات الكتيره بتتكلم على
فكره واقعه صدام حسين انا وضحته قبل كده
بس اعيد توضيحه تاني ان فكره ان يكون هناك
سلاحا عمره عشرات السنوات وانا رجعت
للتاكد من مصدر عسكري محترم فقال لي لا
ممكن قطع السلاح تستمر تالما يتم تعميرها
وصيانتها واذا تمكنوا من توفير الذخيره
اليها هذا رقم واحد اثنين بقى ليه ممكن
يكون صدام حسين كان حريص ان يعطي
الفلسطينيين عن طريق اليمن سلاحا ايرانيا
وليس سراحا عراقيا ببساطه لانه السلاح
تقدر تعرف مصدره بسهوله يعني اذا كان انا
مثلا سايب بلد زي مصر جالها سلاح روسي عن
طريق اي دوله اخرى فاذا وصل من مصر الى اي
بلد اخرى بيعرف من اين جاء السلاح اذا وصل
السلاح الايراني الى غزه التهمه دائما
هتكون الى ايران اذا كان سلاح ايراني او
سلاح حصلت عليه ايران اما لو اعطى سلاحا
عراقيا ده تفسير يعني فيبقى معروف تماما
ان هذا السلاح كان في حوزه العراق ومنها
انتقل الى الفلسطينيين سؤال اخير واستاذن
في ايجاز معالي الدكتور ا ما معلوماتك عن
مؤتمر باريس تقول لنا ايه هو مؤتمر باريس
ومعلوماتك عنه بايجاز الاعلام الاسرائيلي
بيسمي قمه باريس اربع اطراف طبعا ا مدير
المخابرات المصريه مدير المخابرات القطريه
الامريكيه والاسرائيليه اجتمعوا في باريس
بعد اجتماعات من قبل ا على مستويات اقل في
وارسو في عده دول اوروبيه انما في النهايه
رشح من الاعلام الاسرائيلي بان الخطه
الخاصه بتبادل اطلاق الاسرى
تبلورت وان الرؤيه موجوده ان في عزم ان في
نيه وان المعادله هتكون على دفعات وخلال
60 يوم ل 90 يوم وهد طويله في هذه الوقت
واغاثه اكبر
للقطاع لكن المعادله ان يكون بيتكلم على
اسير اسرائيلي مدني مدني مقابل 100 ل 250
من المعتقلين داخل الفلسطينيين
الاسرائيليه فدي المعادله كان المعادله
الاولانيه واحد قصاد ثلاثه دلوقتي بنتكلم
على واحد قصاد 100 الى 250 ويكون منهم من
تورط او شارك في قتل اسرائيليين هو
اسرائيل بتستخدم التعبير تلطخت ايديهم
بالدماء فده ما يطلعش كانت الاول بتعترض
دلوقتي ما عندهاش مشكله دلوقتي خلاص
تنازلت الحكايه دي ودلوقتي في الصوره برده
السعوديه وان السعوديه تخش ك ده اللي رشح
من الاعلام الاسرائيلي انت عارف دلوقتي في
وفد امني
اسرائيلي هبط ووصل للقاهره منذ ايام
وال المقترحات او المخرجات بتاعه قمه
باريس وصلت لحماس بتدرسها فالجانب السعودي
هو كمان شارك في اللقاءات التاليه لقمه
باريس لتفعيل المخرجات فهو قال انا ما
عنديش مانع من التطبيع انا اشرط دوله
فلسطينيه الجانب الاسرائيلي لكي يكمل
المشهد لكي يسهل الامور نتنياهو امر مدير
المخابرات الاسرائيليه الداخليه والخارجيه
بالتعاطي بايجابيه مع المخرجات الحاجه
الثانيه ان ما فيش مانع ان حماس تكمل اه
ده هو الجديد في المساله الموقف الرسمي
الاسرائيلي تغير تغير بعد ما كان عاد في
تمهيد لراي العام الاسرائيلي الداخلي بان
احنا يا جماعه خلاص يعني القوات نفسها
انهكت الالات المعدات انهكت الجانب
الامريكي بيقول
هبطا الذخيره هبطا شحنات الاسلحه ف
الموجود دلوقتي ممكن نخرج
محتجزين انا جزيل الشكر معالي الدكتور انت
يعني خدتنا في اطلاله جميله وواسعه يعني
وان كانت في امور ما زالت تحتاج الى ايضاح
بتا تتضح مع الايام مقررات قمه
باريس الاتفاق اصفر عن ايه شكل نهائي
وامور اخرى كثيره لكن ان شاء الله الحوار
موصول تلغرافات سريعه وربنا يلجم العدوان
دوت وينصف المظلومين امين يا رب ان شاء
الله جزير الشكر معور وشكرا جزيلا
لحضراتكم